[Musik]
ja liebe zuschauer 0 21 hat die deutsche
fußball nationalmannschaft zum auftakt
der fußball em verloren gegen frankreich
was war gut was war schlecht wie geht s
weiter darüber möchte ich heute wieder
reden mit roland zwar dem langjährigen
fußball chef der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung
ja lieber roland die spieler und der
bundestrainer lobte das deutsche spiel
durchaus wie bewertest du die leistung
dieses selbstlob kann ich in gewisser
weise verstehen es war kurz nach dem
spiel und sie hatten ja auch mehr
spielanteile mehr ballbesitz am ende
aber muss unterm strich sagen dabei ist
viel zu wenig herausgekommen
eine einzige tor schoss im ganzen spiel
gegen einige französische plus das
unglückliche eigentor von mats hummels
hat schon gezeigt dass in den
entscheidenden momenten die franzosen
wasser waren und dazu eben auch eine
bessere strategie hatten als die
deutsche mannschaft mit ihrem sehr sehr
starken mittelfeld in denen sowohl
offensive wie defensive akzente gesetzt
wurden vorzugsweise von bock barbara von
conti und von radio der noch einen
pfostenschuss hatte da ist das spiel
entschieden worden sowohl in die eine
wie die andere richtung offensiv wie
defensiv
und da hatte deutschland letztlich nicht
so viel dagegen zu bieten
anders als von dir gewünscht dass jetzt
sofort darüber gesprochen hatten hat ja
sorgt im ich ja auf der rechten seite
gespielt und nicht zentral
ist aus seiner sicht diese taktik
aufgegangen von joachim löw sie ist
schon deshalb nicht aufgegangen weil
josua kimmig ja einen nicht
unerheblichen anteil auch am ersten tor
hatte der im grunde genommen auch durch
eine deutsche fehlerkette ermöglicht
wurde schon bei dem einwurf für
frankreich hat der rüdiger sich von
seinem mann weg bewegt hat den franzosen
dann vor allem pop bei den freiraum
verschafft mit einem wunderbaren
außenrist passt auf ära des zu spielen
und in der nähe leider nur in der nähe
stand der rechte flügelspieler kimmig er
konnte aber nicht mehr eingreifen der
war nicht rechtzeitig daher land ist an
der scharfen flanke zu hindern
hummels ist der geringste vorzumachen
dem ist der ball gegen das schienbein
gesprungen und schon da ins tor
da war einfach keine aktive bewegung und
kein aktives gegensteuern mehr möglich
nach der niederlage ist natürlich der
druck schon gestiegen bei der erben gibt
es nicht so viel raum für
wiedergutmachung wie es vielleicht in
der bundesliga wo anders der fall ist
wie knifflig schätzt durch jetzt die
lager für die deutsche
nationalmannschaft in der
vorrundengruppe schon ein sehr knifflig
denn es sind ja nur drei spiele und das
zweite spiel nachdem weltmeister kommt
dann der europameister portugal die
gestern 13 0 gegen ungarn gewonnen haben
ein ergebnis das zu hoch war die
unternehmen sehr sehr bravourös gekämpft
portugal das spiel habe ich gesehen am
fernseher schien mir nicht so stark wie
frankreich zu sein aber immer noch stark
genug um an einem guten tag auch gegen
deutschland gewinnen zu können
genauso gut ist es aber auch möglich
dass das spiel anders herum ausgeht aber
es wird sehr sehr eng und nach zwei
niederlagen das braucht man ja keinem
mehr zu erzählen gibt es dann nur noch
das spiel gegen ungarn
da setzen wir mal voraus dass die
deutschen gewinnen könnten und am ende
könnte es vielleicht per rechenschieber
reichen um ins achtelfinale zu kommen
das wollen sich die deutschen sicherheit
sparen
es wird aber auch am samstag schwer
genug gegen eine sehr gut aufeinander
abgestimmte und seit jahren
zusammenspielen der portugiesische
mannschaft angesprochen
ein schwieriger gegner auch an
am samstag als wir zum ersten mal
darüber gesprochen haben das gesagt du
bist ein vorsichtiger tipper 1 1 war war
dein tipp das hat nicht ganz hingehauen
wie siehst du es jetzt weg jetzt gegen
portugal aus ja jetzt kommt mal der
optimist in mir durch ich glaube und
hoffe mehr ist dass ich glaube dass die
deutschen das spiel 2 2 1 gewinnen
können und sich damit auch ein bisschen
von ihren von ihren bremsen befreien die
gestern deutlich zu sehen waren sie
wollten alles vielleicht ein bisschen zu
gut machen und haben dabei kämpferisch
zwar überzeugt aber nicht die große
linie gefunden die frankreich auch nur
für eine minute von seinem in sich
ruhenden und auch selbst überzeugung
fundieren kurs abbringen können
spannend wird es auf jeden fall wir
gucken am samstag natürlich auch wieder
ganz genau hin
entsprechend danach darüber zu bewerten
was davon umgesetzt wurde
das kritisiert hast und was nicht so
geklappt hat
vielen dank für das gespräch und die
einschätzung roland lang ihr auch tobias
bis samstag